this video is sponsored by Conan Exiles
age of sorcery do you like large
shirtless muscle-bound men who beat up
evil monsters for a living trick
question everyone does you've probably
heard of Conan Exiles then the brutal
rated M online open World sandbox
Survival game that plays kind of like
Skyrim meets Minecraft but did you know
that the game recently received a
massive new content update that Now
features in the age of sorcery you can
Master dark magic to summon Undead
followers or conjure storms of Darkness
at the cost of your health and stamina
which will visibly alter your body like
Uncle Ben says with great power comes
great popping veins they also revamped
already existing features of the game
like character perks and the building
interface for a much smoother and more
rewarding experience and this is just
the start from now on Conan Exiles will
pass through different ages as time
passes Each of which will come with
their own themes and gameplay updates so
what are you waiting for if you're of
age or have consent from a parent or
Guardian then click the link in the
description below to check out this
phenomenal game and its new update today
and now onto the video
a Zelda game without bosses is like a
pizza with only cheese on it which some
people like but where's the meat where's
the olives where's the pineapple Mamma
Mia just like toppings give a pizza
flavor and complexity Zelda bosses give
Zelda games complexity and flavor and
breath of the wild is no different
though most fans of the franchise know
that breath of the Wild's total boss
count was a bit lacking at least in
comparison to the diversity of bosses in
older games but that doesn't mean there
weren't any bosses so in this video
we're going to continue my series
explaining the in-universe lore behind
the bosses in each and every Zelda game
and if you like these videos check out
the others in the playlist linked below
and subscribe if you haven't already
because next up is Majora's Mask oh and
spoiler alert obviously to start let's
cover the Overworld bosses in the game
which admittedly count for like 107 of
the 114 total bosses in breath of the
wild or a whopping 94 the biggest number
of Overworld bosses comes from two types
of giant monsters the hynx and the stone
Talus hynexes are actually recurring
bosses in the zeld franchise you may
recognize them from their previous
iterations and A Link to the Past Link's
Awakening or A Link Between Worlds in
every appearance they're always giant
cyclops-like enemies although by far
their biggest appearance size wise has
got to be in breath of the wild where
they appear to be oh at least 30 feet
tall or so because hynixes are present
in other games just like the Goblins or
moblins or Liz alfos or even stalfos it
can be assumed that their Origins are
similar to any monster found across
Hyrule which either means that they're
just a natural species of being that
just so happens to be evil or that they
were created by way of the malice of
demise which is a decently widely
believed Theory insinuating that all
monsters across the world of Hyrule or
at least the organic ones are made of
malice which originated from demise
should this be the case then hynaxes are
no different and have simply been
created by Calamity Ganon and just like
most of the other enemies throughout the
game their connection to ganon's
fiendish power according to the
compendium is what results in their
differing colors according to their
individual power levels a couple hynixes
are actually dead and come back to life
as the skeletal versions called Stalin
boxes which is of course due to the
influence of ganon's power and most
likely shares an explanation with all
stall enemies spanning the entire
franchise the bigger question is why
Ganon doesn't just make all of his
monsters immortal like the stall
monsters you'd think that would be a
pretty big brain move who knows maybe
his evil power can only go so far moving
on the stone Talus bosses are quite
literally living rocks that you know try
to commit murder upon seeing link
because they're made of solid rock
they're extremely durable and take very
little damage unless you attack a
certain spot and this spot appears to be
their exposed brain or maybe even a
heart on their central body piece which
normally looks like an ore deposit and
is pretty much the only feasible way to
kill one of these Rocky dudes they also
seem to operate like a hub where really
their little brain deposit is the actual
stone Talus itself and everything else
just kind of sticks on or hovers around
forming arms and legs due to Magic this
enables them to mix and match other
Stone types into their body allowing
them to literally hurl their gigantic
Stone Arms weighing multiple tons
through the air in order to crush your
tiny human skull then just suck some
more rocks out of the ground to create a
new arm like nothing ever happened or
make their entire bodies out of molten
rock or even Frozen Rock now we could
also just say that ganon's power makes
the stone Talus monsters come to life
which is probably true either way but
there does appear to be some strange
things going on with them and patterns
that we can pick up on that would lead
us to believe that there's more to this
picture with regards to how they work
for instance Stone Palace has appear to
grow and mature over time this is
evidenced by the little bitty baby stone
taluses called pebblets that you find
throughout the land followed by the
stone Palace Junior and stone Tellus
senior bosses it could be that stone
taluses are really just little nuclei
that grow as minerals settle around them
leading to them growing or maturing over
time which is how rocks are formed in
real life so this explanation would be
fitting but the biggest question about
these Rock dudes is where did that
little nucleus come from is it a
creation of ganon's because he was just
feeling artistic one day when he saw a
rock for a more thorough Theory check
out this one I did about the possibility
of stone Talus is actually coming from
outer space base I'll link to it below
and be sure to bring your tin hat with
you with the hynaxes and stone taluses
out of the way let's move on to the
molduga this is the rarest kind of
recurring boss in the game and again
reanimates when ganon's power surges
under the light of a Blood Moon so again
it could be assumed that moldugas are
Simply Creations of malice on the other
hand creatures heavily resembling
moldugas can be seen throughout the
franchise as well like the mole dorms
from Twilight Princess which also swim
through the sand or the mulgera boss
from the Wind Waker and yes I will be
doing a wind wicker video soon so stay
tuned however I would like to present
one other possible explanation that ties
the malice Theory into the wildlife of
breath of the wild and that would be
that moldugas could be malice corrupted
sand seals it would make sense given the
corruption that malice is known for and
the fact that moldugas have horizontal
Tails unlike all of the other worm-like
mole enemies spread throughout the
franchise but of course this is just my
theory the biggest molduga is the moldu
king that shows up in breath of the
Wild's DLC but to be honest that's
probably just a bigger sand seal moving
on to the last World boss in the game
which the wiki doesn't count as a boss
but I absolutely do enter the wonderful
peace loving Lionel that's a joke these
things are allergic to peace lionels
have once again had other appearances in
the franchise first appearing in the
first game actually which means that the
centaur-like Lionel as a concept in
Zelda actually predates the bakoblin
which is one of Zelda's most common
enemies in my opinion lionels have
essentially the exact same backstory
slash possible explanations as the
hynexes do they are also biological
monsters that could have either just
been abound in the land of Hyrule or
created purely out of malice one thing
that's notable about them though is
their intelligence which is rather high
for a monster their weapons are forged
for metal like the Liz olfos they can
see through disguises and they equip
multiple different items like a bow and
arrow and sword and shield or spear or
large beat stick the fact that they do
Forge weapons and there are many of them
leads many fans who believe that there
could be camps or communities of lionels
that survive together and share
resources which would only make sense
given that other enemies in the game do
the same thing we never come across a
Lionel camp in game but perhaps we'll
see some of these groups in tears of the
Kingdom as terrifying as that would be
with the world bosses out of the way
it's time to move on to the unique
bosses of the game aside from the final
boss Calamity Ganon and unfortunately
there are only two one of which is
locked behind DLC so really there's only
one in the base game yeah breath of the
wild definitely could have capitalized
on having more unique bosses but anyway
let's start with the one in the base
game the strong the Burly the one the
only Master Koga himself Top Banana of
the yiga clan the yiga clan as most fans
know are defectors of the shika Clan and
as such are the same race of human
beings and feature the same white hair
and red eyes as proven by the x yiga man
we meet in game Dorian the yiga clan has
sworn off their sibling shika clan in
everything they stand for which includes
the Hylian royal family and the Hylian
deities because of this they actually
serve Ganon instead and are both trying
to hasten his resurrection and scouring
the land in search of the hero link just
in case he happens to still be alive 100
years later this command is said to have
been given directly from their leader
and is so ingrained in their brains that
they actually carry out their sworn Duty
even when their leader is taken out of
the picture Koga himself has been alive
for over 100 years according to the age
of Calamity and apparently is the de
facto leader of the yiga and in spite of
his lazy napping nature is actually the
earner of the utmost respect from them
due to his Mastery of secret combat
techniques he claims that his techniques
come from his father's mother's father
which could possibly insinuate that his
bloodline has ruled the yiga clan for
several Generations since the secret
combat techniques that earned him his
respect didn't originate from him and
that's about all we know about Coca
anyway moving on to the next unique boss
in the game monk Maz koshia Maz koshia
is one of the well over 100 chica monks
in the game present within the shrines
that were built over 10 000 years ago
the monks themselves appear to have
committed a process known as
sokushinbutsu which is the real-life
Buddhist art of self-mummification that
almost 20 Japanese shingon monks
actually managed to do between the years
of 1081 and 1903 however even a
mummified human body can only take so
many Millennia and as such all of the
monks in in breath of the wild dissolve
into dust after their shrines are
completed well all except for one Maz
koshia is much more involved with link
than any of the other Shrine monks where
each of them designed their own
respective shrines and normally welcome
link and congratulate him upon
completing their shrines Mas koshiya
actually orchestrates and guides link
telepathically through the entire
Champions ballad questling which takes
place all over Hyrule once link finishes
the many many steps to finding and
completing the much larger final trial
Maz koshia actually proves that these
monks may have still been alive and that
their voices weren't just Echoes of the
past recordings but that they were
really talking to link and may have even
been able to not only move a little but
move a lot Maz koshia actually stands up
in straight up fights Link in what he
refers to as the final trial within the
final trial which is probably one of the
coolest moments in the game it's unknown
what Maz koshia's relationship was to
the other Shrine monks as in whether or
not he was their leader or something but
he definitely was the greatest of them
and I personally like believing that the
shrines and trials in general were all
his idea since he refers to his own as
the final trial a neat little piece of
gameplay and lore that connects the
shika and yiga together would be the
fact that you can drop a banana on the
ground for Maz koshia and he will uh do
this similarly you can drop a banana on
the ground for a yiga soldier and they
will act the same now like I said before
they really are of the same Race So this
banana Obsession seems to run in the
family if you will maskia's fighting
styles are also interesting and allude
to some in-universe lore as well such as
his ability to summon the extremely
similar spiky balls that Koga does
implying that koga's super secret combat
technique is actually a chica one and
that Maz koshia might even be related to
Coca since the technique apparently runs
in koga's family plus koshia and Koga do
actually sound pretty similar perhaps he
even is koga's father's mother's father
I mean these sheikah types do tend to
live a long time maybe the bananas are
the secret to long life anyway koshier
can also duplicate himself which is the
exact same move that impa can pull off
in age of Calamity once again alluding
to chica combat prowess other other than
his moves at trials and potential
relation to Koga though there isn't much
else to talk about regarding monk
Massachusetts so now we'll move on and
let his bones rest once and for all the
final boss bosses we're going to cover
in this video would be that of Calamity
Ganon himself I mean itself and all of
its goons for those who might be
unfamiliar Calamity Ganon is the latest
iteration of Ganon who originates from
Ganondorf more on him in my Ocarina of
Time and Twilight Princess and soon to
be Windwalker boss videos though it is
said that by the time of breath of the
wild Ganon had been defeated and
resurrected Time After Time After Time
again so much so that his eventual
return is something that can be relied
upon prophetically but why is he able to
come back over and over where did
Calamity Ganon even come from great
question and the answer is in my opinion
from demise now buckle up because I'm
going to explain to you my personal
theory on the origins of Calamity Ganon
and Ganon in general which could differ
from your own you are of course free to
believe whichever you want but check
this out demise's Essence is sealed
within the master sword this much is a
fact proven by the ending of Skyward
Sword however before before he Fades
away he promises that an incarnation of
his hatred will forever follow the
bloodline of hylia and the spirit of the
hero all the while laughing his ass off
and kind of having a jolly good time ask
yourself though what's so funny about
losing a battle to a teeny tiny little
insignificant human whelp it's not like
he was able to perform some ritual in
order to bring this curse of his into
life and no offense but that's kind of
poor storytelling if he's able to
literally curse the universe as we know
it by simply thinking it up in his brain
moments before literally being
eradicated from existence this franchise
is a big fan of rituals and Grandeur
happenings that precede major events or
changes in story so if demise who was so
cocky that he would win 20 minutes ago
gets his ass handed to him and is then
unable to perform a curse on hylia then
why is he laughing well I'll tell you
what I think I think demise had already
cursed the world with his malice think
about it he was sealed away in the giant
imprisoned avocado for many years ago by
hylia herself yet monsters still plagued
the surface of early era Hyrule and
these Monsters Just So happen to be
created by less so clearly demise must
have released his mouth into the world
before he was ever imprisoned possibly
back in the age where he and hylia
battled directly and you know what
calamity Ganon is made of malice in its
purest form the culmination of all of
demise's hatred Unleashed upon the
universe in order to be a Scourge upon
hylia's bloodline epitomized into the
Mindless formless monster known as
Calamity Ganon but I hear you wondering
aloud but Bandit how did Ganondorf turn
into Ganon if Calamity Ganon comes from
malice which is separate from Ganondorf
well I'll tell you it's because I
believe that Calamity Ganon and regular
Ganon are two different monsters that's
right you heard me two different things
and for proof of this let's look at the
origin of Ganon canonically he was
created at this moment at the end of
Ocarina of Time When Ganondorf moments
from Death calls upon the power of the
Triforce of power to transform into a
hideous power hungry Pig Beast which is
then killed by Lincoln is never seen
again but banded I hear you wandering
aloud once more Gannon comes back in
other games yes yes he does but as
different ganons each time except for
the Ganon in the link to the past and
onward in this timeline he just Remains
the Same walking on two legs version of
Ganon since the Fallen timeline only
happens if Gannon kills link here at the
end but in Twilight Princess Ganondorf
once again transforms into a Ganon
referred to as dark Beast Ganon who has
a four-legged version created via the
power of the Twilight and is then killed
by Lincoln midna never to be seen again
in Wind Waker since Ganondorf retained
the Triforce of power following his
defeat at the hands of the hero of time
but since Ganon had been killed
previously in Ocarina of Time he instead
infuses a giant freaky transforming
puppet with his power and calls it
puppet Ganon now there are other
appearances of Ganon in the Fallen
timeline but it won't take the time to
go over each of them now my point is
that what if Ganon is the monster that
Ganondorf creates when infused with a
large external source of power be it the
Triforce the Twilight or malice see it's
my opinion that due to seeing
ganondorf's corpse spewing Mal's from
within in the tears of the Kingdom
trailers Calamity Ganon is the
culmination of demise's leftover malice
that has gotten a hold of Ganon dwarf
and used his body over and over and over
again over the countless Millennia to
create many different Calamity ganons
some of which even took different forms
and what's more is that perhaps the
malice appearing in tears of the Kingdom
right around the ganet of course is more
tender-like and thick and deeply red in
color because it's bonded with
ganondorf's blood which resulted in his
drained appearance now the other
versions of Calamity Ganon called the
blight ganons which each take on the
abilities and moves of the Champions
they were responsible for killing 100
years ago are simply extensions of
Calamity Ganon itself since it's just
made of malice anyway and we know that
malice can clearly split apart as much
as it wants to across Hyrule and can
even create other monsters given that it
has bodies to corrupt and therefore
create other ganons should it have a
body like ganondorfs that's powerful
enough to corrupt and wouldn't you know
it we can't find the Champion's bodies
anywhere in the game and their blight
ganons each move just like they do but
for a much deeper dive into what I'm
insinuating here check out my video that
I did on that exact topic linked below
breath of the Wild's bosses weren't
super varied but that doesn't mean there
wasn't lore to explore there's always
more lore and I would love it if you
shared your take on this lore in the
comments below perhaps I missed
something perhaps you learned something
new either way let me know and please
leave a like on the video If you enjoyed
it these do take quite a bit of research
to put together so it's greatly
appreciated also subscribe if you
haven't already because like I said at
the very first the other Zelda games are
on the way so if you love bosses this is
the place to be and there may even be
other series coming soon explaining the
lore about Zelda dungeons so you're
going to want to stay tuned huge thanks
as always to my Bandit crew who make my
day every day and a very warm welcome to
roses red 17 who just joined up right
here on YouTube if you're interested in
helping this channel fly higher check
out the links below or share this video
with a friend that's about all I've got
for this one so be sure to follow me on
my socials and I'll see you next time
this is Bandit signing out peace
[Music]
foreign
[Music]